[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias muchísimas gracias a
todas ya todos
más allá del dinero que te deja tu
trabajo
entre el 55 y el 80 por ciento de la
gente no disfruta de lo que hace en eeuu
el 70% de las personas no tiene un
compromiso real con su trabajo
en este escenario son muy pocas las
empresas que se implican realizar cosas
para que sus empleados puedan tener ese
entorno de felicidad ser más eficientes
y disfrutar día a día con todo este
entorno con todo ese escenario
empresarial dentro de las empresas no es
justo que los millennials se les tache
de ser perezosos narcisistas incapaces
de mantener un trabajo no es justo que
se les tache de esta manera que se les
etiquete simplemente por pensar
diferente por querer vivir experiencias
exprimir la vida además no son culpables
de estar liderados por gente de la
generación x o baby boomers que no
terminan de entender ni los valores ni
la manera de vivir la vida de estos
jóvenes y no es justo no es justo porque
además mucha de esta generación está
viviendo ahora momentos de depresión por
todas estas circunstancias y no es justo
porque además esta generación va en
camino de ser la más capacitada de la
historia dispuesta a entregarse a dar su
tiempo su talento
su energía si conecta con un propósito
no son culpables pero sí que son
responsables de hacer de las próximas
80.000 horas de trabajo que tienen por
delante
una experiencia digna de ser vivida
no puedes tirar a la basura las mejores
horas de los mejores años de tu vida
yo nací a escasos dos meses de ser
catalogado como millennial de hecho me
siento más millennial de corazón que de
cualquier otra generación hoy les quiero
compartir tres claves para hacer de esas
80.000 horas una experiencia digna de
ser vivida
miren hacer las cosas con felicidad en
el trabajo tienen muchísimos beneficios
aumenta tu compromiso mejoran las
relaciones en el entorno laboral das
mejores soluciones y más creativas eres
mucho más productivo y te la pasas bien
y como consecuencia de todo esto es más
posible que alcances el éxito sea cual
sea la definición que cada uno tenga de
ese éxito si el camino es la felicidad
tenemos que buscar estar la mayor
cantidad de tiempo posible en ese estado
emocional sobre todo en el entorno
laboral donde vamos a pasar gran parte
de los días más preciados de nuestra
vida y es en el entorno laboral donde
que hace una distinción muy grande entre
tener un trabajo con propósito o tener
propósito en él
parece un juego de palabras pero no lo
es tener trabajo en el propósito es pues
ya se sabe yo quiero hacer lo que me
gusta lo quiero alinear a mi talento a
lo que el mundo necesita y por lo que me
paguen algo muy diferente es tener
propósito en el trabajo y eso no depende
de las empresas no depende de ellos que
pueden hacer para ti el único
responsable eres tú pero para encontrar
un propuesto del trabajo es importante
que encontremos el significado de un
nuevo concepto el concepto de rediseñar
tu trabajo pero para eso hay que echarle
un par
la primera clave para rediseñar tu
trabajo es rediseñar tu pensamiento
verán sea cual sea nuestro trabajo
tenemos que empezar siempre en mente con
nuestro sueño titánico eso que te motiva
tu macro motivación tu motivación en el
largo plazo tu visión porque sin visión
no hay futuro pero tampoco hay presente
sin visión comenzamos a movernos sin
sentido en lugar de darle sentido al
movimiento
déjenme que les cuente una historia con
26 años me sentía totalmente perdido por
el mundo no tenía significado mi vida
estudiaba una carrera que detestaba y mi
sueño titánico era ser entrenador
profesional de rugby un día mi hermano
me llamó desde francia me dijo gervais
acabo de pagarte dos meses de clases de
inglés en oakland nueva zelanda y dos
meses de una renta allí para que puedas
irte al país donde el rugby es una
religión y aprendas de los mejores
si líder o sin amigos si saber hablar
inglés si absolutamente nada pero una
pasión desbordante me fui a las
antípodas españolas al lugar más alejado
del planeta tierra con respecto a mi
hogar
pero saben que pasaban los dos meses se
me acabaron las clases de inglés el
dinero para la renta y el poco dinero
que había podido ahorrar
fue uno de los momentos más críticos en
toda mi historia nueva zelanda tenía dos
opciones o regresaba a españa donde a
pesar de no desear eso que estaba
viviendo estaba cómodo o me quedaba en
nueva zelanda huyendo hacia adelante
persiguiendo mi sueño la única
posibilidad que encontré para que esto
sucediera fue en un restaurante como
ilegal lavando platos vasos suelos ollas
en definitiva toda la suciedad que
pueden imaginar que se acumula en una
cocina de un restaurante durante 12
horas al día 5 días por semana creo que
durante meses fui el tipo más frustrado
y amargado de todo oakland
hasta que conseguí rediseña mi
pensamiento
desde deje de percibir me como un tipo
grisáceo oscuro amargado lavaplatos
ilegal en oakland y empecé a darle
sentido a cada uno de los platos clavaba
porque hoy comprendí que cada una de
esas decenas de miles de platos que lave
me acercaron a mi sueño titánico y hoy
soy entrenador profesional de rugby no
cambio lo de fuera cambio lo de dentro
mi trabajo seguía siendo el mismo pero
la voluntad y la pasión con la que yo
iba a trabajar aunque fuera un lavador
de platos cambió radicalmente no cambia
lo de fuera cambia lo de dentro rediseña
tus pensamientos la segunda clave para
rediseñar tu trabajo es rediseñar tus
acciones
podemos hacer cada día las cosas desde
tres lugares desde la irresponsabilidad
no hago lo que sé que tengo que hacer
desde la responsabilidad hago lo que sé
que tengo que hacer o desde el
compromiso hago lo que sé que tengo que
hacer con una actitud de servicio brutal
aunque sea lavar platos porque esa
manera de actuar desde el compromiso te
lleva irremediablemente a unos
resultados asombrosos
esa manera de acumular pequeños avances
micro victorias te lleva a avanzar a
progresar esa manera de hacer las cosas
en la selección mexicana de rugby lo
llamamos ser invencible
les cuento otra historia estábamos en
kingston jamaica habíamos sido con la
selección para jugar el día siguiente
allá contra el aquel país la noche
previa al partido tuvo una junta con
todo el grupo les hizo una dinámica de
equipo y al acabar les pregunté si
alguien quería compartir algún
aprendizaje de esa dinámica uno de ellos
quizás el tipo más carismático de la
selección levantó la mano cuando él
hablaba el resto callaba y dijo mañana
debemos de ser invencibles
e invencibles no es no perder
invencibles no dejarte ganar
tú puedes fallar un tag le está
permitido al más alto nivel se fallan
tackles pero la voluntad de pararte del
pasto frío con la cara llena de lodo y
sangre y perseguir a ese tipo una y otra
vez una y otra vez una y otra vez hasta
que le está que has eso está al alcance
de todo el mundo pero no todo el mundo
quiere hacerlo eso es ser invencible
porque esa manera de hacer las cosas
desde la invisibilidad te lleva a
acumular micro victorias avances
progresos y pocas cosas en el mundo del
trabajo te aportan mayor satisfacción y
felicidad que progresar cuando eso
sucede se libera dopamina por todo tu
cuerpo es neurotransmisor a asociar a la
motivación al aprendizaje al estado
emocional y que no solamente se queda en
ti porque todo el mundo que se beneficia
de ver cómo hacen las cosas también
quedan impactadas haz las cosas desde el
compromiso abandona la mediocridad
la tercera clave que les quiero
compartir el día de hoy para poder
rediseñar nuestro trabajo es rediseñar
nuestras relaciones con nosotros mismos
antes que nada y con el resto de las
personas también porque hoy en día es
muy difícil tener y mantener grandes
amigos fuera del entorno laboral porque
no las pasamos o trabajando o con la
familia sin embargo más allá de la
familia de personas son aquellas con las
que van a pasar mayor tiempo a lo largo
de sus vidas esas con las que van a
compartir esas 80 mil horas de trabajo
la buena noticia es que tener amigos muy
buenos en el trabajo tiene unos efectos
brutales mejora tu felicidad mejora tu
salud tu compromiso y tu productividad
pero para convertirte en ese tipo que
genera esas buenas relaciones
tienes que transformarse en ese tipo que
yo llamo ser un gamer 2.0 en el año 2014
fuimos con la selección a bahamas nunca
habíamos ganado bahamas y nunca habíamos
ganado fuera de mexico
al día siguiente del partido cuando
después de aterrizar por la mañana
hicimos una pequeñita activación
mañanera y por la tarde jugamos el
partido en aquella activación maxwell
que el capitán de la selección tuvo unos
desgarros en la ingle dudábamos de si va
a poder jugar o no decidimos darle
chanza que entrara en calor más tarde en
el partido antes del partido y validar
si podría jugar o no podría jugar cuando
empezó el calentamiento me acerqué a él
y le pregunté había max y cómo vas
puedes jugar o no me miró y me dijo
sabes que rubén si me rompo me rompo
jugando no me sorprendió esto lo que me
sorprendió fue lo que pasó a
continuación empezó el partido y a los
escasos 20 minutos más estaba tumbado en
el piso se levantó se echó las manos a
las costillas y siguió jugando
esto sucedió dos veces más a lo largo de
todo el partido él seguía luchando con
su equipo y sigue luchando con su equipo
por conseguir esa ansiada victoria
cuando quedaban solamente diez minutos
para acabar el partido decidí sacarle de
la cancha ya habíamos logrado
prácticamente el resultado favorable él
no pidió el cambio fui yo que lo pedí
cuando llegamos a ciudad de méxico
cuatro días más tarde él fue al médico
me llamó y me dijo que además de los
desgarros en la ingle había jugado con
dos costillas rotas
esta persona jugó un partido de rugby un
combate antes ccoo puro desafío físico
con cuatro desgarros en la ingle y dos
costillas rotas eso en la selección lo
llamamos dar a tu equipo más de lo que
tu equipo espera de ti dar a tu equipo
más de lo que tu equipo espera de ti
además ser un líder 2.0 es ser esa
persona que expresa gratitud a su equipo
que reconoce a su equipo que reconoce
cuando están haciendo las cosas bien que
reconoce los talentos que reconoce
cuando otro está brillando y a pesar de
que tú no lo estás haciendo le ayudas a
que brille más porque sabe lo hermoso de
todo esto
que se quede a una relación de confianza
brutal
con sal de la crema university determinó
que la confianza de un efecto brutal en
el impacto de la felicidad y del equipo
aumenta un 107 por ciento tu energía en
el trabajo un 70 por ciento tu
compromiso un 56 por ciento tu felicidad
dentro del trabajo y un 29 tu felicidad
fuera del trabajo
somos seres sociales por naturaleza por
lo tanto convertirte en ese gamer 2.0 lo
que es importante es que es vital para
pasar por esas 80 mil horas de trabajo
viviendo y generando experiencias dignas
de ser vividas y dignas de ser
compartidas como quieres pasar las
próximas 40 60 80 mil horas de trabajo
que te quedan por delante porque yo no
sé que van a hacer las empresas en ese
sentido si van a ayudar nos van a ayudar
al empleado lo que sí sé y en lo que sí
creo es en nuestros jóvenes que deciden
asumir su liderazgo rediseñar su trabajo
y responsabilizarse de generar su propia
felicidad creo en esos soñadores que se
inspiran de quienes quieren llegar a ser
y usar su trabajo para acercarse poco a
poco a ese sueño creo en esos hombres y
mujeres que hacen las cosas desde el
compromiso poniendo todo su talento al
servicio de la empresa disfrutando día
tras día e impactando en el mundo por
cómo hacen las cosas
en esas personas que deciden
relacionarse bien consigo mismas y con
el resto de las personas que abrazan la
bandera del cambio y deciden actuar
desde el amor y no desde el ego creo en
esos jóvenes que desean y deciden hacer
sus próximas 80.000 horas una
experiencia digna de ser vivida
estás a tan solo una decisión de
comenzar la aventura actúa ya el
antídoto al miedo es la acción no te
pierdas la vida revisión a tu trabajo
con un par se invencible
está en tus manos muchas gracias